T
THEY HAVE DONE IN NEVADA.
>> MUCH MORE ON THAT AHEAD TO
ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT AFTER
TOLD TO BE RESIGN OR FIRED CHRIS
MAGNUS STEPPED DOWN NEWS COMING
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT
AFTER DHS SECRETARY ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS GIVEN HIM ULTIMATUM
THAT CLAIM OR SOUTHERN BORDER IS
SECURE.
WE KNOW THAT IS LIE.
ACTING I.C.E. DIRECTOR TOM FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR HOST OF THE
DARK WARS, PODCAST SARAH CARTER
TOM I'LL GO TO YOU FIRST.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE'S THE
FALL GUY WHEN THIS IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION POLICY.
ISN'T HE DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE
WAS TOLD TO DO?
>> EXACTLY.
YOU'VE GOT THAT STRAIGHT.
LOOK, IF MAYORKAS IS TELLING
TRUTH BORDER SECURITY OF
OPERATION OF CONTROL MAGNUS
SHOULD BE GETTING AWARD.
MAGNUS HAS DONE WHAT MAYORKAS
WANTS HIM TO DO THIS ISN'T THE
FAMILY MAYORKAS THIS IS GETTING
RID OF MAGNUS THAT REPUBLICANS
WILL HAVE WHEN THE CONTROL
CONGRESS.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS AND I SAID
FROM ONE DAY MAGNUS WAS OVERSAID
HE WAS A BAD PICK BECAUSE WHEN
HE WAS A CHIEF OF TUCSON HE
ORDERED HIS OFFICERS NOT TO
ASSIST BORDER PATROL OR I.C.E.
IN ANY WAY WHATSOEVER AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS HE ATTACKED ON
BORDER ENFORCE WMENT MORE
SECURITY BORDER OF A LIFETIME
AND SUPPORT SANCTUARY CITIES
THEY HARD HIM FOR HIS IDEOLOGY
HE DID WHAT HE WANT HIM TO DO
NOT ENFORCE LAW AND NOW A
SCAPEGOAT BECAUSE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS ARE COMES THAT'S ONLY
REASON LEAVING.
>> THERE'S SCANDAL AFTER SCANDAL
YOU'VE SEEN AGENTS TURN THEIR
BACK ON THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
LEADERSHIP.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
WHIPPING NOT WHIPPING SCANDAL
THAT HAPPENED AND THESE GUYS ARE
SELL ON DESK DUTY.
IS THIS ENOUGH, THOUGH?
>> OH, OH IT CERTAINLY NOT
ENOUGH I HAVE TO AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ON THIS, IF THIS
WAS THE CASE, THEN BORDERS ARE
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
QOWLD HAVE TO TURN IN HER
RESIGNATION ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
TURN IN HIS RESIGNATION AND
FAILED MISERABLY BUT THIS IS
THEIR POLICY AND JUST LIKE HE
SAID THIS WAS A POLICY THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BY THIS
PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM TESTIFYING
BEFORE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE DOING THIS.
THEY'RE PUSHING HMM OUT OF THE
WAY.
THEY WERE PERFECTLY HAPPY WITH
HIM SLEEPING IN MEETINGS NOT
DOING ANYTHING.
THIS IS JUST COME UP RIGHT NOW.
AND ALSO I THINK WHAT'S REALLY,
REALLY INTERESTING, THEY PUT HIM
THERE BECAUSE HE WAS AN IDEAL
LOG IF EVERYBODY REMEMBERS HE
WROTE A OP-ED IN NEW YORK TIMES
IN 2017 WHERE HE WAS BASHING ON
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
OF THEIR WANTING TO WITHDRAW
MONEY FROM SANCTUARY CITIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
HE WAS A BIG IDEAL LOG HE
BELIEVED IN SANCTUARY CITIES AND
HE BELIEVED IN LESS ENFORCEMENT
WAS BETTER AN NOW THEY'RE JUST
USING HIM AS YOU SAID LAWRENCE
AS A SCAPEGOAT.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THERE'S GOING
TO BE A SHIFT IN BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION POLICY ARE THEY
DOING THIS AS A REACTION TO THE
ELECTION BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
MADE IT VERY CLEAR.
HE AIN'T CHANGING ANYTHING.
>> NO IT'S NOT I USE ANALOGY
THIS MORNING YOU CAN FIRE A
WAITRESS FOR DELIVERING BAD MEAL
TO THE TABLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING
BUT SHONGTS YOU FIRE THE COOK?
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS IS THE
ARCHITECT OF THIS FAILED BOARD
POLICY HE NEEDS TO BE IMPEACHED
AND THAT'S BOTTOM LINE.
AND THIS SHOWS HE'S GUTLESS,
HE'S A COWARD FOR THROWING ALL
MAGNUS AGAIN WORTHLESS TOO.
BUT THES THROW ON HIM WHEN THIS
WAS HIS PLAN AND EVERYBODY DID
EXACTLY WHAT HE WANTED HIM TO
DO.
>> SARAH WHAT SHOULD REPUBLICAN
DOS IF THEY INDEED HAVE CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE?
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY MUST START
HOLDING HEAR PHYSICIAN TO EXPOSE
IT.
I KNOW IT FEELS TO A LOT OF
AMERICANS THAT ISN'T ENOUGH BUT
THAT'S JUST BEGINNING WE NEED TO
EXPOSE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
BECAUSE UNPRNGHTSLY WE'VE
ORDERED BORDERS SO WIDE UNDER
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND SO MANY
PEOPLE LAWRENCE HAVE GOTTEN INTO
THIS COUNTRY THAT I'M AFRAID
THAT THERE'S A REAL NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK HERE AND IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS PEOPLE NEED TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY CAN'T JUST RUN AWAY OR
RESIGN THE FACTS HAVE TO BE LAID
OUT ON THE TABLE BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND PEOPLE NEED
TO